How do you get over feeling like an impostor?
As a new manager,
I feel like I'm about to get found out.
Welcome to leadership,
my friend.
Here's the thing,
here's what you're actually scared of.
What you're scared of most likely is them knowing and finding out that you don't
know everything.
Right?
That's what people don't like to admit when they're wrong.
Yeah.
Yes.
Yeah,
and the thing that you need to know is it's okay.
It's okay not to know everything.
It's perfectly normal to be in a leadership position and not know everything in
the world.
You don't have to know everything about this particular job that you're going
into or what the,
you don't need to know everything.
You don't need to.
What you need to do is go in,
ask questions,
listen to people and say,
Hey,
you know what?
I haven't done this procedure before.
I've never,
I never worked with this piece of equipment for it.
Can you show,
can you walk me through it?
Can you show me how to do it?
I just want to make sure I understand what you're doing.
Make sure I get it.
Oh,
okay.
Now,
it's not an excuse to not know anything because if you're in a leadership
position,
you should be studying and reading and learning about whatever the role you're
in is that you can understand it all.
Study the manuals and the regulations and the procedures,
and I'm not saying to follow all those things blindly without common sense.
No,
that's not what I'm saying,
but there's a knowledge base that you should,
you should acquire very quickly when you roll into a leadership position.
So put the work in and then apply common sense,
but this is the same thing that I say every time somebody asked me about how do
you lead this or how do you lead that?
Or how do you lead New People?
Or how do you lead senior people?
It's the same answer every time.
Be Humble and listen to them beyond time.
Work hard,
treat people with respect,
weigh the decisions carefully.
Talk to people and then make a good decision.
Empower your folks to lead.
Don't micromanage them,
but give them at the same time,
clear guidance about what the expectations are.
It's just leadership.
And when you're a new leader,
it's all good.
You don't need to know everything.
You're not expected to know everything and showing that you can admit that you
don't know everything isn't going to hurt your reputation.
It's actually going to help you reputation.
And some go in,
be humble,
ask some good questions,
learn as fast as you can,
and it's okay.
And you know,
I was thinking about this,
um,
in the 80s,
and perhaps even in the 90s when guys were losing their hair and going bald,
right?
They do a comb-over.
So they try and pull their hair over their balding scalp.
So it did look like they were going bald.
And I'm telling you as a leader,
don't do a leadership comb-over do what guys do now,
which is they just shaved their head.
Right?
Hey,
you know what?
I,
I'm,
I'm going a little,
a little fed up top.
All good.
Just going to shave it off.
Yeah.
Hey,
I'm your new leader.
Don't know everything.
It's all good.
Here's where I,
here's where I'm weak.
Give me a hand.
Yeah,
no big deal.
That's a good analogy.
By the way,
don't do too little silver call over
the what?
Tell me if you would agree with this.
Generally speaking.
Um,
you're watching a movie demolition man with the as the best alone Wesley snipes.
Negative.
Anyway,
Dennis,
I think his name is Dennis leary.
It doesn't seem like your kind of movie,
but maybe it would be,
I don't know.
Anyway,
densely or he's this kind of underground,
um,
rebel cause basically La is,
this is a long explanation.
I'll make you sure.
Don't want to,
Shit.
It has to do with leadership though for,
okay,
I'm ready.
So I'm all about leadership.
Basically the,
you know,
it's in the future,
whatever.
And um,
the,
the world is turning into this like over sensitized.
Like you can't swear,
he can't eat junk food.
It's the law.
Like,
you know,
so everyone's all nice and real weak and stuff like that.
But there's a group of people who rebelled against it,
went underground,
right.
And the leader of those guys is called egg Edgar friendly.
Right?
And so they go down and he's regarded as this huge criminal,
right?
The demolition comes back.
Long story about him.
But anyway,
he's back to help rid the world of these criminals.
So he goes in,
he encounters Edgar friendly,
and they're not rebel.
They're not these evil people.
They're just like,
just trying to live basically a freedom of free life,
you know?
And they're like,
oh.
He's like,
Hey,
well why don't you lead these people outta here?
Right.
And he's like,
I'm the leader.
Sometimes I do some shit and people come with me.
Right.
That's kind of what he says.
So isn't this his?
So here's the question.
Sorry for long explanation.
Here's
how this guy's,
he's kind of like worried about people finding him out that he's not a leader.
Right?
Isn't that like a huge sign of humility that he's like on the inside,
he's not.
I know everything,
you know,
and that's Kinda like,
man,
I don't know it all,
you know,
and I'm worried about this.
It's actually a good sign.
You are correct.
It's a good sign when you've got someone who's like,
man,
I want to do good.
He wants to do a good job.
He wants [inaudible],
he wants to good job.
And he's like worried about it,
so that's,
that is good.
That is a good thing.
Yeah.
It's like his humility is like,
it's so genuine that that's one of his many worries of being a leader.
You know that it's a good sign.
It's better than someone says,
you know what I'm about to take over as a new leader.
Yeah.
And I'm on this thing.
I'm going to own
everything and no one knows anything that I know.
So it's gonna Right?
Yeah.
You don't want to be that guy.